ben est pas là mais où la sueur twitch
comme ouais mais en fait assez et
bergers partout du bitstream on sait pas
comment ça se passera en deux on ne
comprend rien fait mais on est bien
quelle est l'adresse quoi c'est tout
juste réponse est oui check point comme
je ne sais quoi c'est week à ce point
comme je ne sais pas vraiment me street
s'est cachée non mais c'est pas à cacher
parce qu'en fait ça normalement bliss
rim les berges si j'ai bien fait le truc
normalement
alors
ouais voilà tu es bien tu es bien tu es
sur l'écran un petit fabi mis un petit
lac du jeudi ça faisait longtemps
ouais aussi light du jeudi alors est ce
que tu veux faire des bulles est comme
en fait je vais enchaîner avec l'arena
king derrière ok je suis un peu des
pilotes quoi si tu veux faire un peu des
bullet je vais de suivre parce que comme
ça j'ai peut-être pas trop chauffer
direct voie ouest et la bonne cadence
bon après je suis au dessus de tout
comment savoir donc c'est très long live
ce soir du coup tu veux changer mais
changer de chaîne pas géré ça tout le
savoir c'est c'est écrit quoi pas
vraiment lui dire ça sera vérifiable un
fab mais par contre on s'assure thiès
comme tv se sont encore un peu de monde
a il faut que tu t'appliques il faut que
tu t'appliques femmes allez vas-y fabas
les faits nous et je fais nous un jeu
je lance avec retour d'où toutes ou
certaines six hundred aller face à levon
pape alé fadli mis à les femmes libye
fadli l'ifab libye fab libye
ça a l'air super con comme live le jeu
son loup il mettant une semi méthode
ruiz dégage fast rex 1 le mec a l'air
complètement débile je suis sûr que ils
pourront des pièces en espérant que
faire des prêts move serait possible
demain la vidéo sur tube urines qui sort
sur la chaîne
toi tu es super job ça fait du bien
dormir
j'ai envie que l'on me alié naquirent en
entrée allait rentrer en plein débit du
stream n est ce que tu veux dire bonjour
aux gens
il fait trop froid il fait froid apab le
blizzard cannoise là partout tout le
temps mais il fait je crois j'ai pas
celle où match à cannes en tant que
stéphanoise cette famille on ne te crois
pas non moi j'ai pas trop froid quoi ça
va me manquer ce que c'est que ça
n'entre retour mais bon je reviens je
reviens tu es là non je suis là c'est
que je reviens à quoi tu es là non je
suis la table un point pour latifa bout
1-0 pour fab libye 1-0 pour le jour mais
plus 43 points comme ça raconte
équitable est plus forte que la mienne
gbc tu avoueras attention fab 5 tu
parles très très fort
non mais c'est l inverse en fait c'est
ma voix qui n'est pas forte sur sur le
truc tu pas prêt c'est mon micro qui est
acquis et paf on attend 10 po niveau
battant pourquoi il pas univers
dione huit sports oms la personne
n'accepte pas ce qui se passe à cessange
je t'attaque concurrence attention ok
mais c'est parce que ce n'est pas décidé
que skype skype s'est pris au sérieux
quant à skype annihilerait je je je
modifie je modifie ton micro comme j'ai
envie eh ben non moi je te dis faut il
voulait régler automatiquement la
puissance de mon micro ben moi je te dis
non moi je suis je mets au micro comme
j'en vis avec vous je très énervé par ce
qui arrive ça y est la scène je suis de
nouveau énervé allez hop skype dégage
non mais tu été acheté par microsoft tu
fais de la merde tu ne m'intéresse plus
nous n'utiliserons plus jamais battu
contre var 10 99 kazakhstan attention
l'âme de mur tu as toujours là partout
tout le temps et du coup face chance
celui fils il a disparu
ouais mais puis l'homme
non ma tante i 1 parce qu'il ya quand
même quatre personnes là sur le live
c'est intéressant et a du coup est ce
que la chaîne bitstream les berges en
fait y'a un truc qui m'intéressait c'est
ce qu'ont à l'hébergement automatique
comment ça marche pourquoi comment on
vit bien ben non c'est les berges poteau
matic mans attend on prend tout ce qu'il
se passe quoi non mais en fait je viens
justement on est là pour apprendre
les bleus ont sans s'en prendre aux les
champions au nom non non non non non ne
me bats les confronte le même temps de
faire ça c'était john allen wright est
devenu champion
à l'épée stater on est huit personnes
non chaska mais pas bien ce crime c'est
bizarre parce qu'en fait le big three
normalement normalement automatiquement
elles devraient faiblement automatique
du truc quoi donc on ne comprend pas
pourquoi je vais envoyer autant peu de
montreux prend des conduites ont fait
glisser de cette merde où il est tombé
qui a défoncé boom fab libye femmes
libye fab libye fab libye zf qui permet
je comprends pas avait vécu et comment
ça marche pourquoi je sais grammy en
hébergement hôtelier mis le truc en
hébergement automatique fin à meilleurs
buzz de compteurs en fait on est plus
que 11,2 en et 12 ont envoyé des gens
qui arrivent mais c'est censé être
hébergés automatiquement par le truc
annoncé ça y est non merde c'est pas
mais non mais comment ça marche
le personnel est une en mai je comprends
pas j'ai du gmi le truc
bon j'ai dit aux toasts à configurer
maintenant voici comment tiens c'est mal
configuré fait très attention
non mais j'ai configuré dégage fallu ebe
fable il dit bon c'est parce que je
pousse tout partout ça n'a aucun sens
avait activé j'active s'activer
qu est ce que c est bien d autres
maillons de chaîne votre équipe
sélectionnée vers mars que vous n'êtes
pas en ligne non
merde je tente de faire écartelé quoi un
très bien je celle de pions braves gens
n'est pas vraiment je sais pas tu
entends je check et si ça marche on est
quatorze on est dix sept bouts 17
spectateurs
[Musique]
écoute ce que ça donne tout ce que ça
donne magnolia ça fait marrer qui avait
que 18 personnes âgées ou en islande
perez ouais mais afflux de stream de
jeudi va chercher pas ce qui se passe
avec ses primes du jeudi mais en fait
sur twitter c'est ça le truc ce canton
et parler avec fab le truc tweet chasse
comme et to you tube machin c'est qu'en
fait sur youtube ça envoie des notices
donc les gens le savent les gens ils
sont là ah bon il ya un stream enfin
faut le savoir de bastia ne dansez et du
coup je voulais tester en voyant est ce
que comme on a fait tous les stream et
machin les trucs on en fait je comprends
pas pourquoi je réussis pas à mettre
l'hébergement sur la chaîne du stream en
fait je suis en pls je comprends pas
pourquoi
ce que chanel et bergie j'ai mis ce
combat
je comprends pas papa est ce que c'est
un boom bassong et maxime fait boum et
tu vois je m'attends à un peu plus dans
l'esprit tu vois je j'attends que tu
donnes une qualité quoi tu tu gagnes du
matin à quoi ça sert qu'est-ce qui est
comme chanson avec à quoi ça sert à quoi
ça sert non il joue un footballeur
anglais fab
c'est pour ça que boue est partout
parler je comprends et un truc
d'hébergement je suis en pls je joue ou
baratin pour le mans clairement ça ne
marche pas le coût d'hébergement
je vais faire un nouveau test
ou alors c'est le truc qui bat guingamp
se serrèrent moi donc je ne sais pas en
tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que je
comprends rien donc ces attentions
tiens non et pourtant c'est sur les
berges en automatique et tout cas non je
comprends pas je vais tenter un double
double regard est à partir on va voir
ben faleh tu tentes rien c'est ça marche
tout seul pas faut se calmer des jolis
attentiste comprend un statut rien ouais
mon truc
ça tu te défonces 1 il ya trois ans pour
le moment foe 5 c'est génial c'était
peut-être le coup le moins bon de la
position non wattpad ya pire dans les
coups qui donne pas de pièces en un coup
might be made a été trop intacte tu
parle en anglais qua non mais attends
l'aller en train de te dépasser je pense
qu'il est dans l'esprit il est en train
de se marcher dessus d'une force là
comment tu te fais marcher dessus fab
pour wife de rôle à la fat existe plus
là commenté mme al taqwa larbitre t'as
quoi tu as deux pions de plus tard c'est
un seul bras ça va encore ta qu'un pion
plus jamais comme avant mais n'est pas
fort heureusement qu'il ya bac et ours
et un pour lui un ait eu donne un
deuxième pion mais quel beau joueur ce
mardi 99
oh là là on le sent dans l'esprit
beaucoup plus que toi quoi voilà la hi
hi hi hi femme n'a fait aucun doute
c'est bien joué et bien joué ça bravo à
est-ce que tu as le pion à ses le beau
jeu fable pions v5 est ce qu'il va il
n'a pas fait foudre il aurait pu gagner
il aurait plus beaucoup sur des trucs tu
as tout le temps après si tu perds
faudra dire que c'est une stratégie
grains quelque part tu avais du mal à
enfin comment résister à un tel esprit
quoi en fait c'est ça que j'ai envie de
tenir le mec est beaucoup plus dans
l'esprit que toi dans cette partie ça
serait vraiment mérité pour lui
bravo fav c'est bien jouer et à le
mecque un fou de castres en face tu mets
tout et pions sur noir voilà c'est que
c'est beau que c'est beau femmes
compréhension stratégique supérieure
côté côté fabi toujours toujours
toujours les pions sur la couleur du fou
adverse on le dira jamais assez femme
grosse technique
enfin plus trop de temps femme qui va
gratter le pion attention loti va
pousser et femmes qui merde est reparti
vardy 99 au dessus de tout fab un vote
les pauvres pendule ouais mais c'est
parce qu'il était dans l'esprit l'esprit
tata brouillé quoi une espèce dhombres
alors l'ombre de qui on ne sait pas mais
c'est une ombre qui t'a quitte à
surplomber fab une ombre surplombante ce
qu'on peut appeler aussi longs bras
d'asse surplombe ada nombre à la surtout
on va la fab l'ombre surplombante 1
comme on dit en dans un langage eux qui
n'est pas le nôtre un peut-être dans les
comtés française mais en navarre on
parle évidemment différemment fab à
tours a choisi le beau jeu c'est le beau
jeu fable qui qui passe sa tour sur la
troisième rangée est ce qu'il va jouer
g3 au prochain coup en fermant la
tourache 3 qui serait comme un coup de
très près au niveau fab
fa qui tente le tout pour le tout qui
échangent les pièces ces petits jeux
petit robe boule la colonie est ouvert
du rock de ce côté-là fantastique n'en
avais vardi je le sens très chaud fab un
regard regarde comment on regarde
regarde le beaujolais va te faire
tourner et 5 3 5 ha la la quel beau
joueur
on se demande si c'est pas mal a
d'ailleurs rappelé au kazakh à tomber
trois bien je les factures résiste à
l'esprit attention la malle 5 ça va
chauffer femme qui défend tous olalala
la dame prend d un math fab
moi je leur demande d'être rapidement
séparé de m
ça donne un truc mais peut-être dû damas
deux mais peut-être que tu sauvé tout a
été dépassé par l'esprit de mardi vardy
99 j'ai envie de dire pour nos amis
francophones qui n'est pas avoir du mal
à comprendre 99 je chambre de toulouse
castres 10-9 faut faire des maths fait
très attention c'est très compliqué
c'est très étonnant ce truc quand même
en 99 quand même 90 ou 80 alors j'ai ouï
dire que ça aurait pu être des trucs
pour gratter un petit billet passer
avant les gens machin quand il écrivait
plus tu écrit deux lettres plus été payé
quoi a d'abord fait très attention 90 il
ya que trois lettres jaunes qu'après 40
et 90 quand même beaucoup plus longs
quoi c'est très intéressant
je m'entendais parisien ce truc
qu'est ce que c'est que ça j'étais
finale
car elle a cessé pour les femmes à la
gagne et ça l'a serré que la manoeuvre
pour ses huit tours à huit pour perdre
le pion à était quand même supérieur à
tous et donc femme qui est beaucoup
mieux ouais c'est le beau jeu qui avait
pranger 7 au lieu de prendre la tour f 8
elle a enfin battu quand même contre un
adversaire redoutable nomme ces cas de
présomption fou il est bien quoi elle
dit eh bien bon je suis en quoi qu'est
ce que c'est que ça en fait je vous
réponds pas mal de mecs qui sortent et
koné bas début je me tente le laisse en
fait chez ba c'est est-ce que c'est
cesser si c'est moi qui suis en train de
te de techno ça venait du coeur fabre
ton nom tu as peur qu'il fasse son
rachat et qui dévastera suite match et
on peut le comprendre
aïe aïe aïe mais fab femmes qui donnent
la dame qui se fait plaise à l'effet
mauchauffée allez je me concentre et
sommes allés femmes qui se concentrent
bas les femmes qui s'énerve femme qui
est la boum le cas déjà l'adversaire le
sang la concentration de fab fable qui
est en train de faire un peu comme dans
x-men quoi avec les pilotes qui se
concentre sur l'esprit de l'adversaire
tu ne peux pas jouer tu ne peux pas
jouer est le mec qui est parti on va
aborder gagné 4-3 fait très attention
dégage enfin je vais te dire que les
gens d'hier était très très heureux de
la master class une master class de
haute volée master class qui a fait
progresser tout j'ai gagné a gagné 100 à
sa pas aux portes
non non oui c'est fantastique fab belle
victoire juste une concentration assez
bof ah ben tu as réussi à te concentrer
pour que l'adversaire depuis ce que je
bougeais avec un avec un système de
paralysie et a réussi aussi à cannes
avec une autre une autre puissance
cérébrale à changer le code de
tchatche.com pendant le truc c'est beau
l'accord reprend sur notre anglais faut
quand même que cette phase très très
attention dans le chat c'est jacky je
vois pas comment ça pourrait se
concentrer
j'aurais couper ton micro depuis un
moment et il met un tag le lol alors
fait très attention ça pue ça je vais
peut-être te bannir de cette chaîne
ça fera ça va faire du ménage attention
cette chape gens en danger alors que
fabien joue contre 1 contre être un
compatriote uteq
c'est presque envie de dire uteq ce qui
est ce que c'est lui ce qui vient
je suis inventé la maman je veux mon
temps que le changement change les dames
c'est le beau jeu fable et changé d'âme
je ne bouge pas bref quel très attention
en train de bouger
tel un poisson avec ses écailles fab les
écailles de poisson la cecc arias des le
poisson c'est trop con mais moi ça me
fait rire en fait c'est au tour du 3
dégage avec ta qualité de merde je te la
rend folle suite c'était quand même 30
ainsi que ces cas là c'est le poisson
mais même moi je me fait rire c'est
grave alors que steve ça qui seront des
pénalités sur lynch est ce à cause de
ces des connexions s'asséchant benali
das nietzsche et sauces mais la perte il
va perdre ses pions à mais t'as pas fait
droit à six pour aller bouffer non non
qu'auriez vous fait à 7 en fait j'ai
peur que ça ne t'intéresse pas s'il va
maintenant comme qui a peut-être tard en
fait bon batman mayotte faire ces quatre
pouces et 5 quand même comme dirait
mathieu quand même ça trop froid dire
que voilà ça va aller mais ça aurait pu
être froid dire quand même j'adorais
cette expression de maths cornette
s'arrête refroidir c'est génial quoi
tasser avec suprématie qui ça fait
tellement longtemps que j'étais plus
venu sur recevoir vos là est vrai t'as
bien fait quoi fin fut bombardé trop des
chocs on a trop parlé d'échec pendant
trois ans ferme a fait on a fait des
lives de merde ya moi j'ai senti que
c'était de la merde y avait beaucoup de
monde c'est surtout le dernier jour
quand j'ai eu un en 1901 person who you
[ __ ] qu'est ce que tu fais de la merde
arrête-toi fin heureusement que ça
s'arrêtait femme un jour de pluie sont
atteignez les 2000 alors la pâte a
dominé non pas ses objectifs 2009
attention cette somme ce pourrait être
le titre d'un bouquin je suis plus fou
que j'avais en fait tu te fous que
j'aime 4 à peron qui serait que là on et
28 c qualitatif mais complètement
aberrant mais en fait y'a jamais
personne sur sept chaînes twitch en fait
mais jamais les gens jamais les gens
n'ont jamais pris le réflexe de venir en
fait mais d'armes ni sur le thème sur le
100 which en fait ya eu du monde
uniquement parce qu'on faisait les
prélats y avait tout quoi mais avec les
gens ont pris l'habitude ce que les
candidats c'était long mais s'ils n'y a
jamais personne n'a bien joué mais c'est
beau quel poison cycling sic pour le
tour des candidats tous les jours j'ai 3
2 qui fut tout en cours de vous mais
après trois motifs d'ailleurs 6,40
aurait dû en avoir deux maxi en fait je
m'en prenais pas sur une chaise comme tv
pourront enfin je comprends rien fait
je crois absolument un truc en fait je
suis combien de ventes et alès femmes
non mais parce qu'en fait c'est un mec
qui fait une simultanée complètement
débile et à ok bon d'accord m'intéresse
des gosses au dessus non mais en fait
c'est débile mais kleiza simultanée
enfin on s'en foutra simultanées enfin
dégage quoi ouais je comprends pas
pourquoi tu ne dégage pas non plus mais
je suis en train de regarder ça
simultanée de merde il va me donner une
pièce avec hâte la gamme pour ses six
échecs tonton tu auras regarder le live
il a 20 hockey ils à tours foot pions
contre tours cavaliers de quatre pions
et ils finissent à simultané le tuf et
ours et 6 échecs hyper le fou ces deux
il va voir pièce trois pions de moins et
c'est pour voir cette annonce il a une
autre partie où il est en train de se
hisser fait défoncer il est en train de
prendre très cher le même moi j'ai envie
de regarder l'autre live du coup le mec
se fait tellement défoncé le fion assez
fantastique mais quelques tours c'est
ici lors bls pièce 3 qui ont - ils
abandonnent pas quoi ah non mais ça
c'est un coup illégal qui vous offre un
jouet dégage mama keïta pièce rafion
moins quand on abandonne non il
réfléchit à l'échangé des tours comme ça
comme ça ils taolu d'avoir tous qu'ils
ont contre tours 4 ans à tubes
mais c'est complètement ridicule ce
qu'il fait bon ça moi j'en ai gagné à
windsor vie je me bats mais ce qu'est ce
que c'est que cette simultanée de merde
tiens proulx freppel simultanée géante
pour les 10000 abonnés ouais moussa
balla sur youtube enfin mais c'est
compliqué je me devais sur internet je
sais pas faut qu'on réfléchisse qu'est
ce qu'on va faire passer dix mille
abonnés je suis pas
des idées dans le chatt atteinte à 30
bus en même temps bates et les maires
d'autres que c'est la crème de la crème
quoi la crémade et la crème à bayonne
art espagnol as
fabián kétal tétanos et notre versailles
ou quoi saad versailles aux déchets
spinto comme et non non non non esta qui
restent à kiel aux boulettes hausse le
scudetto c'est pas ringard et si toi
dans les oreilles peux tu vécu des
personnes les plus cons du district wam
a saisi très compliqué je veux rien
calculé ils valent une quand moi je joue
ce que c'est c'est encore pire qu'à faf
coq comment je fais quelques mois ah
merde le mec volodia 49 il est pas
mauvais il est complètement se classer
là bas ne joue pas quoi dégage tant
mieux pour lui c'est que ça allait blum
vous avez qu à faire venir des gaz
négatives possibles
non en fait roblochon se fait très
longtemps que j'ai compris que pour que
la chaîne vitrine commence enfin
vraiment à marcher faux faux me dégager
mois en fait j'ai compris que j'ai
compris que j'étais le fond du problème
en fait
[Musique]
c'est n'importe quoi le cheval
maintenant de mettre tout le monde à
elle qu'à rallier celle ci est à zorro
cancun sous cape à la capa negra
capablanca c'est vrai que tu desseigne
même plus de suivre les vagues quoiqu'à
panega djaraf c'était vaut quand même
non alors je peux plus rien faire je
leur ai dit de ne pas écouter mais en
fait rien n'a pas des grecs capable en
cas c'était dur quand même salle et
d'autres savoirs est très très loin qu'à
savoir des jo s'est pas déjà la chanson
un cavalier qui surgit de la nuit
non non vers la vente au zoo son nom est
aussi à la pointe de son épée
l'inde est de dire si ces regards 0 en
fait le sel c'est complètement c'est
complètement con le refrain dans une
cuillère zorro faf on a compris qu'il
leur faudra alors élevées que part en
couille pas rose au fujian nov
j'adore 00 j'avais adoré le film avec
catherine zeta-jones et banderas ouais
il était de partouzes euro est restée
qu'il entre donc hopkins temps il tombe
est possible tu as tes traits minyana
catherine zeta-jones toujours temps
non c'est pas ça d'un coup les sujets
beaucoup plus intéressant et plus calmes
h4
bhutta gauche à qui ça passe toujours
zorro le dimanche soir il ya toujours la
chanson zorozora ou sépia qui consentent
très très bien ça fait quand même très
attention c'est le deuxième
avertissement il est très taquin web
qu'il fasse très attention
je distribue les cartons rose sept chats
fait très attention piste référence à
booba fait attention carton rose
ouais il avait mis un carton rose à
cynique ceux-ci qui lui avaient fait 1
il avait fait un clash et il avait dit
je te mets un carton rouge attention la
prochaine fois c'est qu'avec acheta un
carton jaune pour ce carton rouge et
dubaï avait fait moi je distribue les
cartons autre est quand même très
attention j'avais adoré
john terry va cartonner rose sait pas
quoi faire un détour de son placement
mais sacrifiées quoi être intéressant
mais sont fous sont fous avec trois
assez fort en france deux en échec deux
échecs trois échecs s'arrête a repris le
dessus et tu te prends corruption même
pas un échec je bougeais toute façon ah
ben tiens je te prends mais l'a compris
le bien des cas pareils mais sans s'en
fout il est moins bien autant tu fais
tomber mais surtout que nous pensons
très fade avait peut-être fou g5 avant
comme quand même très attention
ah mais c'est bien que tu es compris
l'esprit quoi les pièces les pièces
inactiver tout ça c'est bien que sais je
suis heureux tu commences à comprendre
vraiment l'intérêt enfin tu voit petit à
petit tous les concepts commence à
devenir en tête quoi inactivité des
pièces contrôle des ailes don de
matériel faiblesse de son propre droit
fin c'est toi c'est beau quelque part de
devoir progresser comme ça te voir
t'épanouir départ tu t'es pas nous y
quoi guy bono
j'adore seulement épanoui en fait ya
beaucoup de voyages je pense j'aime bien
et moi il ya beaucoup de voyelles dire
que le mot français il ya le plus de
voyelles c'est une question pour le
genre de scrabble club et candy scrabble
en espagne tu as déjà quand tu ne sais
pas dire ce qui est agréable et je pense
et scrabble et c'est ici nous allons
remettre d es devant les tribunaux
militaires on va passer jusqu'à
l'appeler bon ça ressemble absolument
rien ce que je veux
paris garde à cetto negev est ce que ce
serait possible et des jouets ou d'un
parti comme très fabjan et non ce ne
serait pas possible et on l'a déjà fait
s oui difficile est à ce moment
difficile et vous garez vous garer comme
fabiano
or là on est quand même complètement sûr
que ton adversaire tu donnes une
revanche le mec s'appelle rematch
balance une pièce on sait pas ces hommes
là même nom mais le mec est très très
fort je m'attends pas à la parade
joueurs d'un coup dans une combine de
ouf
bon bah revanche on va voir s'il
parvient à son nom oui la défends tu as
si calme et ça se passe comment ton
torneo sur les îles canaries
ça va ça va j'ai quoi je cinq et demi
sur ce trou j'ai envie de te dire trois
nuls on imagine les quatre victoires je
me souviens pas mais l'homme qui ne
permet pas pour l'instant de dire à quoi
l'homme qui ne permet pas pour l'instant
ce serait génial comme monde série dira
il reste des occasions quand même tu
sais quand tu joue demain n'ont pas
encore donné toujours mais sont tous en
train de jouer mais j'ai fait n'importe
quoi
fantastique points et j'adore j'adore je
suis rentré dans ton cerveau quoi tu
n'en peut toujours pour moi je montre
laurent à la volée j'étais inconscient
juste le cloud prend des cinq je m'en
vais apprendre notre côté on va
contraindre à ces jeux il est vite c'est
pas très grave
oui tu perds tu perds pas grand chose en
fait juste un cafouillage 5-1 nous votre
cause et moi votre attention et c'est
que si tu veux le contre la nuit petkoff
way belle partie
c'est intéressant ouais c'est une partie
très intéressant c'était une saveur
entre des changes très intéressante
j'aurais pu dire c'était pas très
symétriques comme partir
bâle est génial votre parti démocratique
mallet s'est passé m'a jouée comme moi
tu es truc je suit une menace rien mais
le mec ça nous appelons ps quand même
nom mais il faut que tu défendes tu fais
semblant d'attaqué tu fais une étude up
ouais bien jouer belle tu défends bouloc
mais est ce que c'est vraiment à quelque
chose on sait pas à quoi je peux me
foutais là pour votre papa de seconde
ouais mais attend peut-être
au fin fonds perdus du parti tour des
trois non non je pense qu'il avait prévu
le tour des trois schémas auriez aussi
touran miami ont souvent d'ailleurs elle
torneo des miami modélisme et de travail
sera un truc en espagnol sandrine bader
qui n'existe pas c'est génial on est
intéressante mais en fait
ouais si camille à la poutre ouais bah
maso il aime bien
non mais on aime bien tous la poutre
mais je pense qu'il va perdre contre
contre la tour ce qui joue contre john
isner
j'aime bien isnard aussi en fait ouais
mais des grands mais sa forme son finish
mais je préfère isnard à karlovic choix
nous ont échoué je te parle pas
d'anastasia shepard niveau les barbares
anastasia liukin anastasia quand même
peut-être sans que le beauf alors témoin
de mal mais on va dire mec qui s'appelle
kevin en quarts de finale kevin anderson
quoi le mec il est là quoi
c'est un deal kevin mais plus fort de
l'histoire du tennis
ouais il va les mecs s'appelle kevin
du coup je suis pour lui quoi enfin
c'est une espèce de mais tu sais que
c'est assez rare comme prénom cabine en
fait non bafin de six mois des sportifs
de haut niveau de sa peine kevin monk et
kevin monnet paquet
ok mais c'est par un sportif de haut
niveau face à kevin gameiro mais bon
j'ai retrouvé la chanson sur gameiro
d'air
touchez pas gameiro ah c'est ça on va la
retrouver en entier quoi mais tabac
[Musique]
touchez pas gameiro
le moustoir ricol à la boue touchez pas
gameiro bien héros fantastiques mais
doivent pas du tout comprendre de quoi
on parle c'est génial j'aimerais faire
un remix en anglais encore plus con dont
teutch gameiro a mis en examen j'ai pris
ça ici pas quoi peut maintenant le we
will you que fais tu je sais pas je sais
pas je sais plus je sentais à l'aise
touchez pas mais il connaissait pas ça
qui merci infiniment
ob graspa jacques matte et j'espère
comme des clochards
on dit qu'à kevin meilleur avec les
numéros de décathlon lé bon enfin pour
l'instant
non mais c'est pas mais parlait mois
parlez-moi tennis parlez-moi foot
parlez-moi basket c'est vrai il ya
peut-être durant ce pas kevin durant nba
mais s'il n'y a pas de tu as des kelly
on n'a pas énormément kevins pas ici
bon je crois qu'il est en place le jeu
assez semblerait que le mec s'appelle
riz match quand même pas fait quand même
très très attention pour lui qu'il en
pls
mais dans les échecs il ya eu comme qui
comme kevin kevin vraiment fort je joins
pas quoi ouais mais c'est prague est
enfin c'est quand même après son blog
son blog est excellent un clean sky est
photo y est allé voir les enfants qui a
une faille faire les enfants non les
adultes ces enfants vous ne pourrez pas
mais il est devenu complètement taré
n'en finissent pas y est adada
d'ailleurs bon cesser écrit qu'en russie
il ya déjà sales of bon il est là quoi
caruana caruana ça commence par ce par
ca et carlson aussi fait très attention
j'ai candidats des trucs et quand même
je te jure il est déjà là il a déjà
écrit un article est tout ouïe csii
histoire de ce choc et je vais les mecs
te dis que tous les trois échecs sont
truquées pas assez fantastique
j'adore il est très très chaud enfin il
était complètement sûr que ce serait
caruana ou cardiaque il en fait il avait
aucun doute en tout cas l'an passé déjà
la même chose en fait c'est déjà karekin
enfin c'est un cas mais c'est pareil en
fait ça se lit pareil en fait il est
expliqué okc enfin ben il y avait aucun
doute en fait c'est soit l'un soit
l'autre je sais pas peut-être vraiment
un truc bizarre avec sa page c'est pas
comme on l'expliqué pas
non mais c'est vrai que c'est une
coïncidence 20 hockey c'est juste une
coïncidence mais enfin j'ai faut le
savoir quoi faire une forteresse
forteresse au cours de l'installation
continue bien les contre attaques j'ai
pas s'y prendre du roi c'est très
intelligent n'est pas là pour ça je
m'active pour mieux reculer attaqué six
qui avaient franchi les 4 hommes ait
appris que chacun atteignant pls total
la maintenant je trouve ça atroce lâche
je lui contre jeu de tous les étages et
tutus colmate avec le roi pas foutu pour
nice à elle va tu t'es tu t'es raté un
essai paraphé à leur base devant
d'autres baissent encore plus et du coup
je la ressens j'entends des gamins dans
son hôtel depuis le début en fait ce
qu'ils disent ah oui je suis pas sûr
dans la rue en fête
mais moi je me fous de couleurs en fait
je comprends bien fait ça ici bref un
non match passé sa semaine sainte
ce n'est pas en vacances tu n'as pas le
droit de tout souci mais j'ai remarqué
qu'en espagne c'est sur ces gamins
dehors mamiza d'un bas c'est bien ils
jouent dehors une première à fait comme
les autres
tu prends ta tablette ton smartphone
ferait sentir mais vont fermer l'antenne
le 3 qui sont beaucoup plus intelligents
ont connu ce segment au dessus c'est
quand même la base fab
lorsqu'on prend la 2 de tout prendre
quoi comment ça pullule de matériel sony
sous peuple et on se fie à ces petits
joueurs sa fab savate retomber dessus je
vais comme ça la semana santa
de pouvoir toutes ces pièces socheat ils
en ont à quelques à safin anton tournoi
mais le taux de femmes n'est pas fini on
ne sait pas encore c'est en cours des
matchs s'il joue comme ça pendant ton
tournoi on est bien quand même
c'est quand même du gros gros niveau
mais du coup il ya des gens qui te parle
de la chaîne de la chaîne youtube et des
gens quittent écrivait tout coiffé tout
le temps quand ils sont tout en bas quoi
tout ça bah je sais pas
tournoi tuer des gens qui écrivent sur
skype de temps en temps et tous nos
banques connaît quoi qui ne connaît pas
quoi faire droite on est content mais du
coup on est tous il est toujours en
train de faire sa sultan mais ça abusé
qu'est ce qu'il a comme position de mr
j'aimerais presque stream et le stream
de l'autre c'est ce serait presque même
plus un concept que de jouer de ce crime
et des parties simultanées complètement
débile et samedi ça se foutent de ce
hack du boxeur grève ça passe pour être
très marrant comme ce qui manquait ce
que vous en pensez les mecs dessous de
la monaque régal être complètement
dégoûté assez méchant bah c'est parce
que c'est méchant qu'on a envie de le
faire en fait c'est bête et méchant à la
fois ça nous ressemble
mais j'ai pas sinon on est plus
méchanceté ou plus bêtise
[Applaudissements]
mais taiwo hibou inuits et dit salut
salut salut hibou bout à pourquoi inuits
basse et à la noche bon sens votre congé
comme je crois qu'il commence à 30
laisse notre amiri match babani koné
plus bêtes que méchants elle c'est
possible votre photo marion d'ailleurs
qu'on change
moi je te préviens je vais m'inscrire à
venir à l'aréna qui j'ai un objectif
c'est gagner ce tournoi vous nuire c'est
mon seul objectif
parfois quand même j'ai très mal
commencé jetons pas laisser tout ça mais
j'ai quand même fille de 22 places et au
sud hambleton donc j'étais content quoi
un mascara où on en est jeté 80e et
hambleton et et et 78e quoi je dis on je
ne peux pas finir derrière du coup je te
viens de me concentrer de me chauffer
quoi pour le rattraper
comment non
voilà ça c'est mieux et maintenant qui
secoue on sait pas c'est de la merde
pas mal kharja peut-être pris en f3 j'ai
dit tiens c'est comme d'homs comme de la
merde
si le temps passe hara kiri c'est
journal bête et méchant genre en
bitstream chaîne bête et méchante mais
nous on est quand même plus con que
quand même mais je pense que la bêtise
c'est quand même marque de fabrique
qu'est ce qu'une envie de te dire on
pourrait dire visserie mme chen d'échec
un peu de bêtises dans ce monde
d'intelligence
ça va durer arnaque et sa femme un jour
le pas ces derniers mois en gros faire
au match
du coup faible j'étais en train de
bosser ici sur les dispositifs pour pour
le champion du monde de novembre là bas
j'ai eu des petites idées
bon déjà je pense qu'on va faire de
vidéo fera faire le live une vidéo de
résumé de la partie même savoir beaucoup
trop beau bah ouais enfin on peut pas
mettre en pause non mais en fait j'ai
déjà prévu plein d'invités là pour te
permettre de te reposer pendant en fait
aidé de pouvoir éclipsé pour faire
l'analyse de la partie en fait pour
faire un système complètement complet si
tu as un système intelligent serait très
bizarre puisque à plein de gens qui
veulent venir pour le commenter en fait
tact et ceux qui sont venus tout ça fait
tout le monde est chaud pour passer en
fait donc j'ai déjà trouvé 5 5 invités
minimum de marc demarcq et j'ai pas
encore parlé à vlad ça pourrait faire si
ces murs parce ça pourrait faire cette
tu vois si tu as déjà sept invités tu
commences à avoir le temps de faire des
trucs non mais bon puisque ce que je
suis mieux placé pour faire l'analyse
alors le mieux placé je te cache pas que
c'est vlad
mais ce qu'il voudra on ne sait pas pour
le moment mais les analystes se sera pas
forcément toujours la même personne qui
fera près toutefois ce sera toi une fois
sera pas une fois ce sera là d'une fois
peut-être toit soit 3 toi une stratégie
une fois ce seront trois femmes
bref à battre ce nom mais peut-être
peut-être vlad peut-être tu vois
peut-être celle qui sera chaud pour en
faire une quoi j'ai pas fait exprès de
changer sydom mai mais du coup ça en
fait c'est eu du coup on va faire les
deux tu vois on va faire et la partie en
direct et l'analyse de la partie tout en
sachant que l'analyse de la partie on
peut la préparer pendant la partie aussi
vu qu'à certains moments les mecs sont
capables de jouer pendant des heures
sans rien faire on doit se mettre sur
l'ordi et analysé sa part et la vidéo
mais ça va vraiment faire un très gros
truc infâme donc je vais te mettre au
courant parce que c'était pas au courant
fait non
mais alors est ce que ce sera surtout il
joue pas je ne sais pas encore je sais
pas si on refait tout ici on fait
inutilement fait d'escalier quoi j'ai
pas encore décidé femmes youtube youtube
pas sûr parce que si site oui je réussis
à négocier la première page tu vois ça
on peut voir non non ça va ouais je
souris qui partent coupe luc mory quoi
c'est en train de jouer un coup et puis
par ceux de quotas mais ça arrive des
fois donc ouais c'est un peu l'idée
femmes
non mais ça va être bien de faire de
faire le truc en direct plus une vidéo
de résumer mais en fait on fera une
vidéo courte du coup de résumer
l'objectif c'est de ces deux là si tu
vois ses deux papas pas forcément faire
un truc méga complet peut-être quand on
aura déjà le live tous que ce soit chez
n'importe quoi est ce que tu es enceinte
par ce truc champion du monde
voilà je suis jean pellez mis au point
pour préparer des trucs machins quoi
t'as pas pris en quatre jeux blancs
cette méthode depuis que j'ai fait deux
le machin au début ça m'a froissé car il
faut faire l'esprit l'esprit d'esprit
non mais c'est simple à préparer des
trucs pareils à faire c'est intéressant
comme match et on verra qu'il y aura des
parties qui seront un peu insipide
forcément de temps en temps ce sera pas
que cela vous espérons comme de
l'insipidité partout tout le temps
non mais y aura des parties non il y
aura des parties courtes c'est sûr géré
par la ce sera pas que des partis à très
longue
c'est super intéressant
je trouve tout cool je me choque mais
c'est pas vrai civile à des choses peut
être très intéressant les analyses de
vlad bas mot 10 secondes c'est beaucoup
trop
ouais viser les analyses de blattes ça
peut être très intéressant
ça c'est la route je suis reçue n'a pas
le choix at hulot chez diane est quoi ce
que la halle est en grand danger quoi
sourire est ce que tu perds ta face
entre autres celle ci dit sur cette
partie là bas dans ma roue qui rejoint
avec nous l'année prochaine en pro de
chez sting évidemment comme ça ne fait
aucun doute
1 mais ils jouent bien en fait c'est
juste qu'il est passé à travers mais je
comprends toujours pas pourquoi pour
pourquoi ça a pas héberger la chaîne la
chaîne chaise comme michel je comprends
en fait non et donc quoi elles pendant
le pendant le truc en fait bon à ça je
pense qu'en novembre thual j'aurais
nouvel ordinateur et où tu vois en fait
ça se peut largement que autant
situation l'a pas fait parce qu'il est
quand même bien partie intéressante
autant là je sais pas si les gens seront
content mais je compte bien jouer à des
jeux vidéo pendant le cas parce que le
délit peut y avoir des parties très très
longue nous
effectivement ça va être ça risque
d'être longue
ouais mais ce sera intéressant aussi je
pense a peut être un beau match
as tu remarqué les baies 5 pouces et 6 à
nom d'un chien mais je pense que tu
pouvais rien faire en fait je regardais
pas n'importe quoi de la merde que les
allemands reason dommage parce que je
crois que c'était gagné
mais bon je dis ben arous qui te marche
dessus hein
pendant cinq minutes à l'aréna king je
vais je vais le stream et sur la chaîne
blisstree de soissons ce rôle savard
c'est écrit c'est vérifiable
du coup si vous voulez le suivre et vous
savez où faut aller la route va jouer
l'aréna bah en fait qu'il suivait arena
et que tu ne stream pas en direct tu
n'as aucune chance de rien gagné donc je
sais pas s'il va le jouer messi stream
pas le 65 e mail arena qui va être joué
quasiment toutes les semaines sur la
chaîne bitstream je mettrai des
calendriers tout ça faut le savoir mais
ce sera pas toujours moi qui le jour est
des fois sera fab
des fois ce sera cette joie de fo sera
sylvain une fois sera maxime lagarde fin
moi ya pas mal de gens qui vont venir le
jouer je pense femme tentera sa chance
quand il sera chez lui pour raser 175
quand même 75 sebo fable sur une soirée
centos ntmk essink way dans l'arrêt ce
qui en fait depuis qu'on regarde là car
l'ol pape elle aussi on a beaucoup plus
envie de parler espagnol va dire tu sais
que la chanson de bella ciao c'est la
chanson des résistants italien oui moi
je sens doctrine chanson résistants bon
goût fait de la merde à chaque partisan
la hat avait tourte avait tourné avec
cavaliers trois tours 2-1 qui avait fait
quatre tués benjoin en fait je t'écoute
part mais je jure que je calcule rien je
peux faire aucune tactique en fait quand
même partie que jouer des coups un peu
où je passe mes pièces mais je crois pas
un instant mais quand même je pouvais
gagner une kalach jeter coup de parler
plus intéressant que de jouer du coup
ouais non mais c'est connu on fait comme
chanson moi je connaissais par exemple
mais normal que je suis d'origine
italienne tu vois normal que je
connaisse
cette chanson
c'est des jolies paroles la chanson en
général c'est une jolie chanson c'est
assez dark knight c'est pas la chanson
de résistants jour là réside sans tu as
en sorte à la fin quoi banon mais en
gros il dit enfin ça finisse comme ça
qu'on a eu de la chance si on est morts
pour la liberté quoi
mais les mecs se meurt en fait à la fin
la chanson enfin ils sont pas censés
résisté et gagné le truc tu vois mon
[ __ ]
vraiment il ya terminé déjà escaladé le
papel quelque part grâce à nous je pense
qu'il a regardé complètement petit ravin
il a il a terminé la série la casa del
papel moi j'ai vu que la première saison
en fait sur netflix et du coin non mais
c'est une bonne série c'est un peu quand
même parfois et quelques intrigues qui
sont un peu abusé non
enfin j'ai trouvé je sais pas ce que ton
à penser toit des trucs tu sais pas
pourquoi mais c'est comme ça
ouais y'a pas mal de trucs qu'on sait
pas pourquoi cette rue qui se passe ton
à la série t pas tu te dis pourquoi quoi
bon leur semblait tranquillement mais
bon j'aime bien le personnage principal
vous trouvez ça ouais tout élire sur mac
hasard non noir est possible merci
mais bon j'aime bien aussi le nom quand
el profesor j'ai pas l'air assez sympa
non la rigeur de visages ou pas le fait
d'être un mec cool je parle de l'acteur
je parle pas de mec dans la série donc
voilà aussi c'est quand même pas sûr
mais quand même un objectif qui veut
voler ton fric mort je le tiens si je
suis dans mes personnes souffrent il
fait attention car il va 10v d euros du
plan d'affaires de l'inflation et ça
ajoute à tout le monde
graf
je pense que lui il a bien compris la
phrase du grand paris quoi donne un gun
un homme il braquera une bombe d'une
banque un homme ivre à accra le long lui
je pense qu'il est vraiment là dedans
enfin m enfin on va filer moi je vais
aller que je vais aller jouer le truc je
met le titre je vais mettre le don
switch point tv stage ni de stream si
vous voulez suivre l'aréna j'ai filé
jouer l'aréna bonne chance à fab trop se
fier sur la chaîne switch sur tout le
monde aille